Україна готова наростити свою присутність
у миротворчих місіях у низці регіонів, якщо в цьому буде необхідність,
заявив цього тижня президент Порошенко.
Та чи варто збільшувати український контингент
миротворців по світу, якщо в самій Україні війна?
Нині понад 400 українських військовослужбовців
беруть участь у 9 миротворчих операціях, зокрема
у Конго, Південному Судані, Косові та на Кіпрі.
Це місії з підтримки миру та безпеки під проводом
ООН, НАТО та в інших форматах.
Починаючи з1992 року, в міжнародних
миротворчих операціях взяли участь загалом
понад 42 тисячі українських військовослужбовців.
Півсотні з них загинули.
Війна на Донбасі змістила акценти.
На думку військових експертів, нині
доцільність розширення українського миротворчого контингенту
за кордоном залежить насамперед від завдань місії.
Приміром, саперів, як це було в Афганістані,
тепер немає можливості відправляти.
Навантаження на інженерні війська з розмінування
на Донбасі і так велике.
Також вертолітні загони,
якими у світі добре відома Україна,
нині потрібні вдома. Минулого місяця з Ліберії
повернулися близько 80 українських миротворців
зі складу 56-го окремого вертолітного загону.
Це була одна з найдовших українських миротворчих місій.
Вона тривала майже 14 років. Українські ударні
та військово-транспортні гелікоптери здійснили
понад 55 тисяч вильотів. Досвід вертолітників
тепер має стати в нагоді на Донбасі.
На думку військових експертів, безболісно
для своєї обороноздатності Україна може
відправляти хіба що загони хімічної безпеки.
Решта, включаючи медперсонал, необхідні
на передовій або для тренувально-навчальних завдань.
Утім, це не означає, що потрібно припинити
участь України в миротворчих місіях в інших країнах світу.
Навпаки. Співпраця щонайменше на рівні
штабних офіцерів та спостерігачів була б дуже корисна
для українських збройних сил. Цей досвід
потім застосують у зоні АТО. Крім того, те,
що українські "блакитні шоломи" понад чверть століття
були в багатьох гарячих точках у світі і сприяли там
мирному врегулюванню конфліктів, тепер збільшує
авторитет України і шанси отримати
миротворчу операцію на Донбасі саме на умовах
Києва, а не Москви. Передусім, щоб
"блакитні шоломи" були розміщені не вздовж
нинішньої лінії зіткнення, як цього прагне Кремль,
а на українсько-російському кордоні.